tomorrow marks 20 years since 9 11 when
terrorists killed nearly 3 000 americans
and left many more with long-term health
issues hillary clinton visited ground
zero in manhattan after the attacks and
she had been sworn in as new york's
junior senator just eight months earlier
on 9 11 she said she hoped the
catastrophe would unite the entire
civilized world former secretary of
state clinton joins us now madam
secretary good morning to you
i think your hope for a united world
came true if only briefly and i want to
get to where we are today all these
years later
but let's stick with the memories for a
moment you were a new senator in
washington d.c on 9 11 when you think
back to that day what stands out to you
what stands out
is the overwhelming
sense of
devastation and tragedy
i was on my way to the senate for a
hearing about improving education
actually
laura bush was scheduled to testify when
the first plane hit and
after making sure that my
entire staff was safe and that they
could relocate
out of the
capitol area so that we could begin
working
on i was on the phone endlessly talking
with elected officials in the state
obviously people in washington
and
looking at the television like every
american was glued to the scenes of
devastation
but i have to tell you that when i went
the next day
with my colleague senator schumer we
were the only plane in the sky other
than fighter jets that were keeping
cover over
new york and other parts of our country
we landed at laguardia we took a
helicopter and we circled over
ground zero
and i cannot imagine anything that
looked more like the gates of hell
i thought i'd be prepared because i'd
seen it on tv but the tv screen
contained it and
circling over it
was something that i think about and
will never forget
but then quickly we had to support our
first responders other emergency workers
who were running toward danger not away
from it we had to support
the families whose loved ones were
literally
lost and a second
we had so much work to do and in a way
it kept me going uh in the face of such
overwhelming uh tragedy and of course we
were
concerned that there might be more
attacks elsewhere in our country
and really it's the people who i met
that i worked with
over those years and still today i was
interviewing some for my my podcast that
reminded me of the heroism and
determination and tenacity
and as you said the overwhelming sense
at that time was of unity
and
it really was an incredible moment of
the country and the world coming
together
yeah madam secretary i don't think unity
would be a word that people use to
describe
america today or the world today those
attacks changed us in more ways than we
can enumerate if you had to pick one or
two
what are the biggest changes to our
country to the world because of what
happened on 9 11.
i think that uh
we have to keep
in mind that we did have unity then it
means it's possible and i would hate to
give up on it
but clearly we were changed once you've
been attacked as we were
we made some smart moves some not so
smart moves to try to protect ourselves
and our friends and allies and people
across the globe
we also tried i think to show our spirit
of resolution and resilience and as a
senator from new york working to rebuild
lower manhattan i saw that every single
day how people pick themselves up
how people in the midst of incredible
grief and loss uh figured out how they
could keep going so i keep almost this
duality in mind
uh the tragedy the devastation the
attacks what we had to do in the
immediate aftermath some of the
decisions that were made but also
the way that it lifted us up and
i know we're in a really divided country
right now i understand that completely
but boy do i wish that we could be
reminded
of the courage and the resilience and
the tenacity and the unity that we all
experienced 20 years ago
you know madam secretary we have a new
home here on times square and as
thrilled as i am to be here i admit i'm
a little nervous sometimes i'm looking
around more than i normally do
and i think a lot of americans are
concerned about a threat risk here in
the united states because of our
withdrawal from afghanistan do you share
those concerns
i think you always have to be
vigilant gail and and certainly that
unfortunately comes with living in the
world as we know it today but actually i
am more concerned about internal threats
we always have to be aware of and
protect against external threats
but what really is tearing our country
apart and threatening our democracy is
what we saw on january 6th
and i unfortunately have seen so much of
that kind of continuing divisiveness and
hatred and
ideological
attitudes about our democracy about each
other
so yes we have to be constantly aware of
potential
damage attacks threats from outside
but i think every american regardless of
where you stand on the political
spectrum
should be as worried if not more right
now about what we're doing to ourselves
you know we can take anything we can we
can overcome anything we can come back
from anything if we're if we're united
but if we are going to continue to
uh hate each other uh scapegoat each
other uh try to undermine each other go
after our institutions our our voting
system
uh yeah then we are putting ourselves at
great risk and that's what keeps me up
at night these days
yeah you raise a very good point already
there's discussion on whether we should
put the barbed wire back up at the
capitol people aren't thinking about
that for no reason yeah make a very good
point yeah and here we are one yeah one
day unfortunately we've got
yeah we've got we've got another um
gathering at the capitol that
is supposed to take place and
i guess next week and honestly
uh every fair-minded
american should should want the laws
enforced and protect our democracy
madam secretary uh you made a really
good point earlier about how 911 was so
big it was really bigger than tv but
we're doing our best here to memorialize
it today 20 years later thank you for
helping us in that effort
thank you thank you all